we'll, I told you yesterday that it was likely
to happen soon and it actually happened minutes
after we finished producing yesterday's show.
A Senator Kamala Harris has officially dropped
out of the presidential primary.
She collapsed in the polls over the last few
months, and as I told you yesterday, Kamala
Harris had qualified for the next debate,
which is the sixth debate, I think on December
19th but the polling was just not there.
Her fundraising was just not there, and I'll
tell you, I respect her decision to drop out
at this point in time.
I'm going to address that more in a moment.
Let's look at her polling first.
You will see that despite hitting a national
polling high of about 15% this is her high.
She wasn't leading, but her campaign high
was about 15% that was in the first half of
July.
It's just been downhill for her all the way
down to a national average of barely 3% in
recent weeks.
Now, Camila is not someone that I was supporting.
She has a very troubling record in the criminal
justice system during her time as the attorney
general of California, she was slippery on
healthcare to say the least.
She definitely, uh, brought some clever planned
attacks to the debates.
She had one on Joe Biden in the first debate.
She put together an attack on Telsey Gabbert
at the last one, but it wasn't the sort of
substantive, vended, inspiring candidacy that
did anything for me, particularly her slipperiness
on healthcare.
She wrote in an email to her campaign supporters
to her campaign newsletter quote, my campaign
for president simply doesn't have the financial
resources we need to continue.
I'm not a billionaire.
I can't fund my own campaign.
And as the campaign has gone on, it's become
harder and harder to raise the money we need
to compete in good faith.
I can't tell you my supporters and volunteers
that I have a path forward if I don't believe
I do.
So to you, my supporters, it is with deep
regret, but also with deep gratitude that
I am suspending my campaign today.
Now she's absolutely correct and that's what
gets us back to the respect thing.
Kamala Harris qualified for the next debate,
but she dropped out anyway because she has
no chance.
That is what I respect because most candidates
who have no shot would keep going clogging
up the debate stages because they want FaceTime,
they want the publicity, she realizes she
can't win.
She realizes she's not raising the money she
needs.
Implicit in that also is that she doesn't
have the polling support that would allow
her to raise that money and so she's dropping
out and I respect the fact that she's going
to clear the clear, clear the stage, and not
clog it up with folks that don't have a path
to victory.
Now there's a whole bunch of other people
who should do the same thing and we'll see
if anybody else does between now and December
19th immediate questions about this.
Number one is Kahmilah Harris angling for
a VP spot.
Don't know too early to talk about and quite
frankly, I'm not super interested in talking
about VP stuff yet.
Number two, who will she support or endorse?
Unclear.
There's the idea that for demographic reasons,
maybe it would be Elizabeth Warren.
There's the idea that because of policy, because
she's more of a centrist, it could be Joe
Biden.
I don't think there's too many people thinking
that she would endorse Bernie Sanders, but
you never know.
A more immediate question is where does her
support go?
I actually don't think it's that important
of a question.
She was pulling 3.4% on average as of yesterday
when she decided to drop out.
Every candidate, if they drop out, their support
would be divided among the remaining candidates.
It's not going to go all to one candidate
and however you slice and dice 3.4% it's not
really going to be a game changer, so I'm
not super interested in where it is.
Kamel is 3.4% go, but overall the field is
thinning.
I believe at this point.
That's a good thing.
Lots of the people left don't have a shot
at the nomination.
They're not in the running in any of the first
four primary States, nor are they getting
any traction beyond two or 3% nationally.
It's too late in the game to be clogging up
the debate stage when there are real differences
between the candidates that have a shot.
I welcome a thinning of the debate stage and
we will see if it continues.
Let me know not only what you think of Camila
baling, but more importantly, who else should
bail before the next debate?
I want to hear from you.
Leave a reply.
If you're watching on YouTube, we'll have
a post about this on our Instagram page at
David Pakman show.
Follow us there
and leave me your thoughts there as well.